[Music]
all right let's go out to Triton New
Jersey and talk to the mighty Erica
what's up
Erica hi hi Dr deloney than you for
taking my call of course thanks for
calling what's happening yeah uh well
first I will admit I am very nervous and
two that I'm not a longtime listener um
I just came across your Channel about a
month ago and after binging many of your
episodes I thought you know this guy
seems to know a thing or two and I think
he'd be a great person to ask my
question to so appreciate it welcome
opportunity Welcome to our gang our our
little mad house gang that's not so
little anymore we're super happy to have
you what's up thank you um okay so my
main question is will I regret cutting
ties with my dad um and I guess some sub
questions to like further discuss or
explore would be how do I find peace
with my decision um and if I don't
completely find or feel that peace is it
because it's not the right
choice that's a great question can I
just um answer this off the top of my
head without getting too
deep asking yourself the question am I
going to regret this down the road is
really a recipe for anxiety you're
pre-imaging what the future is going to
hold and you don't know I'd much rather
you ask the question what's the right
decision for me right now that's going
to help me be whole and me be healthy
and me be aligned with my values and my
people that is a much better question
because here's the deal if you decide
for and I don't even know what the story
is on your dad we haven't even got to
that but if you decide for right now I
need to create some space between me and
my mom me and my dad me and my whoever
that's not a declaration of independence
forever that you're not going to circle
back at some point in your life that
means right now I can't breathe and I'm
around that guy I can't sleep I start
spinning out I I need to make some make
some
space and that's right now and that
could be for the next year it could be
the next five years that doesn't mean
forever so um I I I just the question of
am I going to regret this man I don't
even like that
question um because it just it just
assumes that you can read the future and
uh so so what happened all right um so I
guess the backstory would be um my dad
stepped out on his then marriage and had
an affair with my mom um he had two
children at the time um my parents were
never really together so I was raised as
an only child despite having siblings
and when I would ask him about it he
said that they didn't want to have a
relationship with me when the truth was
that they didn't even know about me um
no one did no one on his side of the
that sucks so are you a product of that
Affair yes I said that so ugly are you a
product like you're a loaf of bread
right no um uh
yes okay you're the greatest thing that
ever happened to your mom and your dad
your mom recognizes it and your dad
doesn't so um and then he lied to you
about your
family yes okay and so you grew up
thinking that your half siblings didn't
like you didn't want to talk to you
didn't want anything to do with you
right um I actually I feel like I spent
most of my childhood feeling as if I was
the one having the affair with him
because I knew very little about him
like I didn't know where he lived he had
told me he lived an hour away when he
actually only lived like 20 minutes away
um I didn't have his cell phone number
like our main form of communication was
through email and it was like his work
email at that um we'd have to go like
out of town to hang out so that like he
or we wouldn't be recognized and there
were even a couple of times I can
remember growing up like running into
him in public and he would like look the
other way if if he was with his like now
new family hey hey Erica your dad
sucks and and I say that not even
laughing I'm sorry that that was your
dad and let me let me like be as direct
as I
can um I went to hug my seven-year-old
little girl this morning and she did her
Matrix move which she's been doing much
less recently but but I but I grabbed
air I hugged air and she looked at me
with kind of that ha you missed me and I
had to go and I just said hey I love you
and I almost wept on the way to the
car because
I can't breathe without my daughter in
the
room and you deserve that
too and you should have had
that I can't even wrap my mind around
seeing my daughter in a strange place
and not having the entire world stop so
I could drop down and give her a
hook your dad sucks your dad's a coward
an absolute Stone coward and I'm sorry
and I would say that to his face if he
was standing two inches from
me I hate that for
you I hate that for you know what I also
hate it for your mom I hate it for your
mom because your mom um deserved better
than that too yeah and I think she
carries a lot of guilt too feeling like
she put me in that situation no no no no
no well she hooked up with a married man
there's that right and there's there's
consequences from that but I don't like
looking at you as consequences right
yeah like you're a gift you're here for
a reason and you probably do a lot of
good in your local community with people
who love you and people you care for so
I the fact that you're here is right and
good but your mom can't feel guilty by
saying
hey father here's your baby girl and
expecting him to act like a a decent
human
being
yeah what a gosh that's that's awful man
I'm sorry I'm
sorry because here's here's what I also
know um I know the downstream ripple
effect of
that is how old are you now 31 a 31y old
woman whose body asks herself every day
what was so bad about me that my dad
wouldn't say I love you and wouldn't
invite me into his life what was so bad
about me and you've probably been trying
to answer that question in some stupid
ways over the years is that fair fair
very fair you're like uh oh
um yeah it's part of your nervous system
I don't think you I mean you may have
made some choices that made your life
really complicated and hard um but I'm
not even I'll call them stupid choices
but I don't think they were dumb I think
your body was doing what it could to try
to solve the question of what's so bad
about
me and I'll find somebody to love me
I'll find something to cover up that
hurt and that's really hard it should
not happened
yeah okay so how can I help what's your
what's your question about future regret
G so hold hold on let me let me this I'm
talking a lot okay is what I'm saying
rink sit with you I mean does it make
sense yeah yeah it took a few weeks to
get to this point with my uh previous
therapist so the fact that we were able
to do that in just a few minutes yeah I
kind of cut through the first three
weeks of therapy
usually yeah um but yeah and so I think
just kind of like add on to the
backstory which kind of leads to my
question is fast forward to um a few
years ago about 2020 we found out that
he had been keeping another secret and
there was another sibling that we didn't
know about no you mean a pathetic liar
who cheats on his wife has other lies
and cheats that he doesn't tell people
about you know and it's funny because
growing up I would always tell my
younger brother who I do have a
relationship with you know like I
wouldn't be surprised if Dad had another
and then boom it happened I was like I
mean just look at his like patterns you
know yeah Tada the sun came up again no
way all right so right you've got other
siblings right and so there's another
one and so despite it being a a
triggering situation um I supported him
through it the best way that I could but
then I soon felt betrayed when I
realized that this new sibling had
already been introduced to his family
and had been to his home and I was like
wait a minute like I'm 31 and I still
haven't experienced that um and that
became a pretty defining moment for me
and that's when I decided to completely
CTI with him um but I go back to that
initial question like I often wonder if
I made the right choice um if I'll
regret it and or if I'm even being
selfish by not allowing him to have a
relationship with my family and like
specifically my daughter I'm going to
tell you something really hard I want
you to internalize this deep in your
soul okay okay he left you you a long
time
ago yeah your dad abandoned you like a
coward and left you the problem is he's
such an extra layer of weak cowardly
man that he left a ribbon out his shut
door for his daughter to hold on
to you ever seen those um they're like
the old science videos that we watch
when we were kids and they're on YouTube
now but you ever heard of like ducks
like baby ducks they imprint and so
they'll have a ducks eggs will hatch and
they'll put a big wire like a like a
wire mesh looking duck in the middle of
the room and these baby ducks are born
and they run in and they imprint on that
metal duck they just the first thing
they see that's Mom that's it and
monkeys do that too they have balloons
monkeys that have like uh imprinted on
balloons and the balloon is their mother
and they'll hang out out and they'll do
everything with
him your dad did that with a shadow of
himself to
you he left you a long time
ago and if you've listened to this show
if you've done a binge on the show and
talked about um like you hear me say
like I think reconciliation is something
to always strive for almost always and I
think forgiveness is something important
to strive for and I I believe
forgiveness works here too because I
don't want you carrying around his cner
blocks everywhere just forgiveness is
for you it's you setting it down I'm not
carrying this stuff for you old man
you're just you're a disturbed cowardly
man that abandoned his
daughter and um I'm not carrying that
anymore your dad did not leave you
because something was wrong with you
Erica he left you because something is
wrong inside of
him
period I think the thing that feels like
regret is deep and profound
heartbreak and it's right and good
because your dad's
awful but the fantasy that he's going to
one day pick up the phone and invite you
to meet your family it's not going to
happen if you want to meet your brothers
and your half brothers and sisters
you're going to have to reach out and
call them and tell
them yeah he's not going to do it you
can't expect a rattlesnake to not bite
you your dad's a coward that's who he is
that's in his DNA he's a cheater he's a
liar that's who he is that's who he's
continued to choose to
be yeah and I think when I when I cut
ties with him I was making that choice
to not allow him to hurt me anymore and
to just control what I could control and
that doesn't mean you did the right
thing and we often think that if we do
the right thing the world just works out
you did the right thing let me say it
like this you can do the right thing and
it still hurts real real
bad yeah you can end I thought I would
you thought you'd feel a different way
right yeah I thought I would feel peace
like okay like a weight has been lifted
off my shoulder and in no in feel gets
heavier yes and here's but here but
you're you're attributing to something
it's not because you're attributing it
to regret which is you blaming yourself
again which is what little girls do when
their dads abandon
them that weight you feel is reality
he's not going to
call he's not ever going to welcome me
in that is called
heartbreak and all of the imaginal
imaginative scenarios all of the
Facebook and emails you get back and
forth all of the little stolen glimpses
you have all of the little access he
gives to you of his
shadow that's not that's not a
relationship with your dad are you
and so I think what you're feeling deep
inside is oh my gosh my dad left his
daughter do you have kids I do my
daughter can you imagine can you just
just just flip it around can you
imagine just your daughter walks up to
you in the mall and you're just like sh
and you walk away I could never yeah I
don't even I can't even wrap my head
around very hard for me yeah it's hard
for me to comprehend that he would do
that and my daughter's mean and she
doesn't like me you know what I mean
like she's me and I still I couldn't I
can't
imagine that level of Despicable
cowardice I can't yeah yeah but but
that's your world that's that's the
truth
right yeah and I think that in in some
ways um I'm like grieving and mourning
like not only the picture that I had of
what my relationship could be with with
my dad but of him and my daughter
because I thought like surely by now
even if he didn't get it right with me
he's gonna do it for her and I realize
that that's not the case and I'm like I
refuse
to I refuse for my daughter to feel what
I did that's right here's here's the
statement where's your daddy my dad's
really
sick his mind in his soul don't work as
they're supposed
to and he's really sick and he had a
hard time telling the truth and he had a
really hard time um with his
babies and it makes mommy sad because I
could never imagine a second without you
in my
life and I think healing for you is um I
would tell you you know what I tell you
I'm going to tell you to to treat this
the same way I would treat you if your
dad had just suddenly passed
away I think it starts with you writing
three
letters one letter
to thank you and I know that sounds
insane thank you for meeting my mom when
you did and for having
me because if it was a one night stand
or a six-month Rendevous whatever I'm
here so thank you for
that the second letter is how freaking
dare
you leave me with a lifetime of
wondering what was so bad about
me and I want you to write that letter
and be bloody honest to yourself honest
to him as though you finally have
permission to say the things that you
need to say and the third letter is Dear
Dad wanted to let you know here's what
you're gonna
miss you're going to miss your amazing
granddaughter and as of now you're never
going to see her because I don't have
her around cowardly weak dishonest
unsafe
Men You're going to miss your daughter
growing up to be an incredible woman and
an incredible hard worker and a great
mother and a great wife a great all of
those
things and I wish you the best and you
end the letter with this from this point
forward I'm not carrying you and your
dysfunction on my back anymore
more love
Erica and God help you don't send these
letters but I want you to fully
experience them I don't want you to do
it when you have the office plane or or
reruns of some murder podcast plan I
want you to write these when your kid is
with a sitter your kids's at school when
you have some time off work when you can
just fully be present with these letters
and they should be really heavy and
really
hard
and then maybe write a fourth letter to
your mom and just say thank you so so
much thank you for being a great mom for
showing up continuing to show up even
though you were kicked to the
margins and thank you for being there
for
us and then just enter into a season of
grief shouldn't be this way but it is
start journaling with yourself this is
how I feel today thank God I have my
daughter thank God I have my mom
thank God I have my husband my partner
thank God thank God thank God next day
man today's really
hard and then you're going to build a
new
picture one that doesn't include
him and maybe one day in 10 years he has
an Awakening a
reckoning and he calls and begs what
have I done I'm so sorry my baby I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry and then maybe you're
whole and you're well and both feet are
of yours are anchored into the ground
and maybe you say I'll meet you for
coffee but if it was me it's for me in
my
house I'd block the
number I'd delete the
email and I would begin to build a world
that already exists in reality and
that's a world without my
dad hate that for you I'm going to send
you building a non-anxious life I think
that might be a great road map for you
to begin to create something new without
and I'm also going to send you own your
past change your future which has a lot
in it about a road map for dealing with
historical trauma and building something
new when everything that you thought was
going to be there for you falls apart
thanks for the call
Erica